Was haben beispielsweise der tasmanische Beutelwolf,
Mammuts und die Wandertaube gemeinsam?
Sie alle gehören auf die Liste der ausgestorbenen
Tierarten.
Und wir Menschen könnten uns schon bald einreihen.
Dramatische Veränderungen auf der Erde könnten
uns Menschen schon in den nächsten 100 Jahren
als Opfer fordern.
Warum manche Experten genau dies vorhersagen
und wie Ernst wir diese Warnungen tatsächlich
nehmen sollten, erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction, gibt es täglich spannende
Science Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Heute mit Cedric von Doktor Whatson: Von allen
Tierarten, die jemals auf der Erde lebten,
sind laut Schätzungen bereits jetzt rund
99 Prozent ausgestorben.
Und schon in wenigen Jahrzehnten wird dies
auch uns Menschen drohen.
Zumindest, wenn man dem Mikrobiologen Frank
Fenner Glauben schenken mag.
Er hat schon vor einiger Zeit in dem Fachmagazin
“Phys Org” (2010) einen Bericht veröffentlicht,
der wirklich alarmierend ist.
Und einige Entwicklungen in den vergangenen
Jahren legen tatsächlich nahe, dass wir seine
Warnung Ernst nehmen sollten!
Auf der Erde sollen sich Fenners Vorhersage
zufolge in naher Zukunft dramatische Veränderungen
ereignen, die das Aussterben der Menschheit
zur Folge haben könnten.
Und Fenner, der 2010 verstorben ist, ist keineswegs
als Spinner in der Fachwelt bekannt - ganz
im Gegenteil.
Er war Zeit seines Lebens weit über sein
Fachgebiet hinaus bekannt und hat zahlreiche
Preise gewonnen - beispielsweise für seinen
Beitrag zur Bekämpfung von Malaria in Neuguinea
während des Zweiten Weltkrieges.
Doch was die Zukunft der Menschheit betrifft,
ist der Forscher wie gesagt alles andere als
optimistisch.
Fenner sah schon im Jahr 2010 vor allem den
Klimawandel als entscheidendes Problem.
Dieser stehe zwar erst am Anfang, doch wird
er laut Fenner das Aussterben der Menschheit
zur Folge haben.
In seinem Aufsatz vergleicht er unseren Untergang
mit dem Schicksal, welches die Menschen auf
der Osterinsel erleiden mussten.
Nachdem sich die ersten Menschen auf der einst
tropischen Insel angesiedelt hatte, wuchs
die Bevölkerung wuchs erst langsam, dann
immer schneller.
Die Wälder wurden gerodet und viele Tiere
starben aus - mit fatalen Folgen.
Um 1600 herum dann brach die Zivilisation
zusammen und war Mitte des 19.
Jahrhunderts komplett verschwunden.
Doch nicht nur Fenner selbst, sondern auch
andere Experten sehen Parallelen zu den aktuellen
Entwicklungen auf unserer Erde.
Der Klimawandel jedenfalls wird seinen Teil
dazu beitragen, dass sich das Leben verändern
wird - so viel steht bereits jetzt fest!
Der letzte Sommer im Jahr 2018 hat selbst
in Deutschland gezeigt, welche Folgen uns
blühen.
Flüsse und Seen trocknen aus; die Spree hier
in Berlin floss rückwärts, die anhaltende
Dürre führt zu Ernte-Ausfällen und somit
stehen weniger Lebensmittel zur Verfügung
als gebraucht werden.
Aber auch andere menschliche Verhaltensweise
könnten zum Aussterben der Menschheit beitragen.
Wie etwa die Rodung von Wäldern, um immer
mehr Infrastruktur zu schaffen.
Pflanzen und Tieren wird damit der Lebensraum
genommen.
Und das bedeutet am Ende auch für uns Menschen
weniger Nahrung.
Auch den Ozeanen könnte Studien zufolge schon
bald der Kollaps drohen.
Die Überfischung der Meere könnte schon
im Jahr 2048 dazu führen, dass keine kommerzielle
Fischerei mehr möglich ist.
Dabei sind einige Milliarden Menschen auf
Fisch und Meeresfrüchte als Nahrung angewiesen.
Laut Fenner wird diese Nahrungsmittelknappheit
zu zahlreichen Kriegen führen, denn immer
mehr Menschen auf der Erde bedeuten auch immer
weniger Ressourcen.
Die Kluft in der Gesellschaft zwischen Arm
und Reich wird immer größer.
Fest steht: Zahlreiche Menschen haben nicht
die Möglichkeit, sich selbst und ihre Familien
mit Essen zu versorgen; in Zukunft wird die
Zahl der Hungertoten wohl noch dramatisch
steigen.
Auf der anderen Seite werden in Ländern wie
Deutschland unfassbar viele Nahrungsmittel
weggeworfen und die Anzahl der fettleibigen
Menschen steigt an.
Und auch Wasser selbst könnte schon bald
auf weiten Teilen der Erde knapp und zum Luxusgut
werden.
Ein Problem eben nicht nur für uns Menschen,
sondern auch für viele andere Lebewesen.
Die britische Zeitung “The Guardian” geht
davon aus, dass schon in knapp 30 Jahren zehn
Prozent aller Pflanzen- und Tierarten ausgestorben
sein könnten - darunter auch Elefanten.
Ob die Vorhersagen tatsächlich schon in Kürze
Realität werden, kann wohl niemand mit hundert
Prozentiger Sicherheit sagen.
Doch abzustreiten ist keineswegs, dass dringender
Handlungsbedarf besteht.
Wir alle können einen Teil dazu beitragen,
etwas zu ändern und unserer Erde und somit
auch unserer eigenen Zukunft etwas Gutes zu
tun.
Ökologische Nachhaltigkeit ist hier das Stichwort.
Beispielsweise können der Verzicht auf Fleisch
und Fisch, das Vermeiden von Plastik und allgemein
ein achtsamer und bewusster Umgang mit Konsumgütern
dabei helfen, die Erde langfristig zu bewahren.
Und sie zu einem sicheren Ort zu machen, an
dem die Menschheit auch weiterhin die Möglichkeit
bekommt, zu existieren.
Vielen Dank Cedric!
Er ist derjenige, der auf YouTube in die Zukunft
schaut und jede Zukunftstechnologie in 10
Minuten erklären kann.
Als unbedingt seinen Kanal hier abonnieren:
Wie immer draufklicken.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!